Hi everybody. Welcome to Web Development. In this course, we're going to
learn how to build web applications together. Over the entire course,
we're going to be basically building a blog. A fully functional blog,
that'll have user registration, submitting
links, viewing, everything together, just like
a real blog. And it'll be online on the real internet,
for you and anybody else to see. And by the end
of this class, in addition to that blog, I'll also get
you to build a wiki as your final exam. And I figure
if you can build a blog and a wiki and get those things online, you can build
just about anything. In this lesson, we're going to take
it from the very top. We'll start with the
internet and browsers, and how these things fit together.
We'll also talk about basic HTML. And we'll develop
a common vocabulary, so [INAUDIBLE] communicate through the rest
of this course. With that said, let's get started.